hacía dos años que no podían asistir
desde la plaza de san pedro cincuenta
mil fieles católicos se reunieron para
la tradicional bendición urbi et orbi
del pontífice butters y fue la guerra en
ucrania la que movilizó gran parte del
mensaje del papa francisco pidió la paz
para este país al que calificó de
martirizado
somos incrédulos en esta semana santa de
guerra hemos visto demasiada sangre
demasiada violencia nuestros corazones
están llenos de miedo y angustia
mientras muchos de nuestros hermanos y
hermanas tienen que encerrarse para
defenderse de las bombas per defenders
ella le bombea conflicto en europa el
papá continuó con el ritual e hizo un
repaso por los conflictos en el mundo
refiriéndose a yemen afganistán etiopía
birmania y la república democrática del
congo
también mencionó la violencia actual en
jerusalén el pontífice abogó por el
acceso libre a los lugares santos post
son israelí danny y palestinos e
israelíes palestinos y todos los que
viven en la ciudad santa así como los
peregrinos conozcan la belleza de la paz
vivan en fraternidad y disfruten del
libre acceso a los lugares santos en el
respeto mutuo de los derechos de cada
uno de geely y de ser uno
el papá también dijo que rezaba más
ampliamente por la paz en oriente medio
desgarrado por años de división y
conflicto